[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash baby you might know something you
might notice something a little
different on this episode and you know
it's because there's a [ __ ] skull and
back of me there's a skull and
everything is a setup this chair you
know if you're watching the video you'll
notice something different if you're
just hearing the sound on the podcast
you won't notice something different
because babies it's the same old me
doing the same old podcast however we
doing it in Albuquerque okay
and I'm live on my app if you can see
also before anybody sees it you go
download my app and all that [ __ ] and
we're live in Albuquerque that's where
we are and it is so Albuquerque and this
studio the rio grande studios helping us
out doing the doing the thing here
that's cool they have a route 66 [ __ ]
thing on their wall and of course of
course you know and that's of course and
then also we've got all sorts of things
around here like everything is brown
everything is mud so Albuquerque has
risen from the mud that's what it seems
like and I'm shooting this movie here
army of the dead I can't I can't really
talk too much about it because they want
it they want to do all this stuff that
they want to talk about all this stuff
and they want to release it and I
respect that but um okay cool so already
one fire is asking to share the Wi-Fi
password now well you didn't do he said
he didn't do it but but it just does
that now does it make me mad yes
is it okay it's fine does it stop what
I'm talking about my stream crisis
yes okay is it are we do we still fly by
the seat of our pants in Albuquerque
yes you know is this the park guys yes
isn't knowing yeah what am I gonna do
about I mean what am I gonna do about it
so um it's all good but we're three
minutes in and we're [ __ ] sailing
already dude we are sailing already I
don't know I feel like I all I want to
do is talk about I got good shorts on we
didn't know the shot was gonna be so why
but I got these [ __ ] tie-dye shorts
on and I am too I'm gonna you guys are
gonna get some crotch shots and guess
what I don't give a [ __ ] dude you know
I'm not PC with the crotch shots I mean
you saw the earlier episodes we haven't
get rid of to tighten it up because you
didn't want you couldn't see the book
you know we don't want you to see the
Bulge dude we didn't want you see the
tie-dyed bulge who was the apartheid
building their whole life mm-hmm and we
still got the ice americano dude they
have iced Americanos in Albuquerque
so everything's mud in Albuquerque and
it's all good
even the Starbucks will have like a
[ __ ] a bunch of wood posts on top of
it that go way over to call them you
know the [ __ ] that hold the roof up
it doesn't matter I guess we just talk
about normal [ __ ] pretend like we're not
in Albuquerque but it's a hundred and
fifty seven degrees out so it you know
it's all good
they got me wearing a [ __ ] flight
flight suit for killing these zombies
and now it's so hot because it's a one
it's like it's basically like the adult
version of pajamas that you'd wear as a
kid a zipped up my penis once on with on
a onesie and it hurts so bad
if it when you zip up your penis in a
onesie it feels like you shot yourself
in the [ __ ] dick it feels like you
just close up point-blank range just one
like this
check it out [ __ ] blam
because it [ __ ] zipped it up this
[ __ ] pain was so sharp and I just
immediately screaming my mom came
running into my mom and said what are
you doing I said I slipped up my penis
in a red onesie hit what kind of a
[ __ ] lunatic parent gets their kid a
onesie for real maybe if you're like too
but I was like 10 in a onesie dude
that's that's not cool if you're a chick
you can wear a onesie all the time but
if you're a dude you can't wear ones
past sick five four four because in your
dick starts to get too big and you're
gonna zip it up
do it my brother's done it I've done it
you know generations of dick zip and
have been going on in Wednesday's
probably also what's up with the onesie
like it's supposed to be cute or what or
like is it is it so you don't have like
too many PJs to put I just put on boxers
and go to bed dude put on if you're if
you're dude put on boxers go to bed if
you're a chick put on a shirt and that's
it go to bed right onesie what are you
doing flying a [ __ ] helicopter or
going to bed anytime you got to put
something on like this it better be a
goddamn backpack in that set and that's
it dude and that's my platform I'm
running for mayor on no ones he's 2020
mayor of Albuquerque also I'd change it
to Albuquerque yeah dude
people like that furry [ __ ] to where
they put on a big like Panda one you're
not it's already cute dude you got a
onesie on why they have to make it an
animal you know animals see [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that and they're just like this
goddamn idiot this [ __ ] idiot college
girl she's gonna dress up like me the
pandas in Japan just like did I've ever
seen chicks at ASU dude they [ __ ]
dress up like us what do you mean they
zip up it's like a onesie why don't they
just put on a shirt on and go to bed
hey that's what I've been saying anyway
watch out for people killing us there's
four pandas left to be a onesie to do
make a onesie to make a onesie with an
animal that's there's almost none of us
yes a dick it's so human you know hey I
got a onesie of a [ __ ] dodo bird hey
dude I got a onesie of a dodo bird and
it's just a [ __ ] big-ass beak on top
of my head also how about the fact that
we named it the dodo bird dude dodo
birds are probably all [ __ ] dead
because they committed suicide because
they were so [ __ ] depressed because
we named them and [ __ ]
hey we got a big even little baby dodo
bird you're like well what are we called
like no you know we will tell you when
you're older we got big ass dumb beaks
and they gotta call us dodo birds
it's like a [ __ ] not even dumb dumb
you know dodo like if you were like if
you were in I in my head and earlier in
the day I got I got in a fake fight with
Mark Wahlberg for no reason you ever do
that you're just like dude what if I was
like working with Mark Wahlberg on a
movie and like he's like started giving
me attitude I'd be like I'll dude I'm
not gonna stand for that like in my head
I was just at drinking coffee I was on
my way to some [ __ ] coffee shop in
Albuquerque that's all painted white
outside that's way too bright hey
Albuquerque
never paint anything outside white do
you know why it reflects the Sun and do
you know that is 1000°
dude I was so ridiculous I parked my car
by the way I got a killer [ __ ] red
Honda rented it and I parked and I went
to the coffee place and there was like
this like outside kind of like mulish
area and it was all painted white and I
was like looking for the coffee place
that I looked up on Yelp and I just
looked like Clint Eastwood trying to do
anything in his life I don't have sight
and bring sunglasses of course and and
oh and the misters were ever dude there
was this burger place next to the
[ __ ] coffee place and there were
these me there was like an outside
seating area and people were sitting
there and it was just mr. so many so
much water that they were just eating
burgers in a lake and people were out
delivering dude I'm sorry but
Albuquerque has it nailed they have it
nailed down cuz who the [ __ ] would want
burgers outside at 12 p.m. when it's a
hundred and two degrees out head Hey
I'll skip the meal hey you want to eat
sure where you want oh we're gonna go
eat burgers in Hell what yeah but
there's a let it's in a lake basically
I'll skip the meal do it hey catch me at
dinner was I talking about Mark Wahlberg
yes so I got a fake
with Mark Wahlberg cuz I don't know why
I think he was like when I was I was in
my head and I was just like kind of
getting the coffee and I was reading the
script and to see how much it changed
from the first draft and then in my head
Mark Wahlberg like I was doing a movie
with him and he was just like I mean
he'll talk to me like that or someone
else I got I didn't mean to do that like
and he was like oh you know he was like
we're not gonna be doing that to me and
then I was like aw dude yo yo hey I'm
not that guy like that's what I was
saying in my head and I know he like
boxes and [ __ ] so I was like okay fine
fine [ __ ] fight I don't even give a
[ __ ] dude if you want to fight fight me
I don't what the [ __ ] do I care and I
had some cool insults I have I have him
locked in my head in case he has her
give her gets in a [ __ ] fight with me
I'm not gonna tell him on the podcast
and I come up with new ones if it really
happens or I guess you use them and
they'll be like fan faves bro I got
insults with so many stars in my head
just in case and then just in case
somebody has a camera on me the lies the
LIA keep coming up with these [ __ ]
cool things before fights he's like the
real Arnold Schwarzenegger remember in
[ __ ] uh the movie uh what the [ __ ]
erase erase erase erase ur eraser where
he plays it I think it's a racer he's in
a movie called eraser Ivan gets rid of
looks at me and says eraser like it's
[ __ ] The Godfather and and he's like
and and there's this one part where any
clones himself so it's about Arnold
Schwarzenegger cloning himself and and
there's two parts there's I don't know
if one of this one may not be an eraser
but he shoots the alligator that's
attacking him hey and he says you
luggage which is dope and now I can't
use that because if it came out like
they're talking I have to think of a new
one but and then there's one that self
essa forced that it was unbelievable so
he'd they clone he clones himself and
[ __ ] and he and they Kelowna many
realizes it or something and
- Andy says he says to the guy who's
like the head bad guy he's like well in
this case he should have you should have
cloned yourself and then the guy says
why is that like [ __ ] like like any
guy here's the other thing - if somebody
was gonna [ __ ] slam me like that and
said well in that case you should have
cloned yourself there's no way I'm sayin
why is that cuz that's given him the
[ __ ] open door to the slam hey dude
no way I go like this alright whatever
bro get out of here and then he can't
say the thing he can't say the thing
dude
[Laughter]
so he says well into the cases should
you should have cloned yourself and then
the bad guy Ron something you know says
well why is that and he says because
then you could have won them gonna [ __ ]
yourself it's the forest sir writing you
know well into the case he should have
cloned himself why is that in the case
he could have [ __ ] yourself somebody
on my app goes alligator is a racer
thanks babies
what is that the thing the sixth day is
the clone 100 the clone one is the sixth
day that's right the six today well in
the case you should have you should the
clone yourself why is that because then
you could have one I'm gonna [ __ ]
yourself oh dude that's great I wish I
could have been in a movie in the 80s
you know I gotta do that I got it I got
a do 80 [ __ ] it's gotta be we got to get
the 80s back I I know everyone says that
because my age says that because they
were grew up in the 80s but I don't know
I don't know it is what and anyway I got
a fake fight mom what Mark Wahlberg in
my head I think he's cool though I like
Mark Wahlberg I just do it for because
I'm bored and that's where I live in my
head all I've ever wanted to do was make
up a world that's it
like maybe that's why I like science
fiction so much like on
I'm in movies and [ __ ] because I get
such a world that's made up like that's
what I do in my head all day long anyway
like I'm literally I'll be in like a
coffee shop and I'll be like what if
[ __ ] you know someone came in with
with just a shirt on and they started
jerking off on everybody's [ __ ] latte
like I've got [ __ ] set for when that
would happen you know it's like when
Eminem is like ah he he's so amazing at
Ron Ron has you keep coming up with
things to rhyme he already knows about
what rhymes like that's why I detect
some detectives are the [ __ ]
and they know what the [ __ ] is they're
constantly thinking like what would
happen in this scenario if I have to
[ __ ] go detect and that's why they're
so good at it you know the guy walks in
is like so what do we got and they're
like well they've got a [ __ ] guy here
and this is in well it looks like some
foul play well how do you know because
the lamps lamps don't go in that
position in this part of town like what
how do you know because I [ __ ]
clocked out the lamps in town really why
just in case just in [ __ ] case um
yeah so so it's like Eminem already
knows what rhymes he's got a database
dude he's not constantly freestyling
thinking of all what's gonna rhyme with
my next thing he knows boom he picked it
out he's a [ __ ] computer remember the
[ __ ] the the old [ __ ] things on in
the internet it was like on Ebaum's
world and it would be the GI Joe thing
anybody like hey kid oh I'm a computer
do you remember that [ __ ] dude you gotta
look that up this [ __ ] let me laugh and
4% know what I'm talking about but it's
okay I'm not explaining [ __ ] dude
I'm not [ __ ] explaining that to you
it's respectful you look it up if you
want if you don't don't waste your time
dude don't be one of those [ __ ] guys
that's like always what did somebody
said something to me the other day they
were like yo you gotta check this out
and it was like a [ __ ] gar a
botanical garden [ __ ] and I'm like
[ __ ] you don't know me dude and
he was describing all the plants and the
and I'm like I don't you're gonna tell
me about plants bro
on what planet do I look like a [ __ ]
botanist I don't I can't you know I like
to learn about what I want to learn
about dude I'll look it up dude but
you're gonna [ __ ] sit there and tell
me about you know like our net
sunglasses
remember those [ __ ] sunglasses dude I
wore our Nets and I swear to God when I
put our net or aren't and P some [ __ ]
asses would call them rnase because they
thought it was like foreign and even if
it is rnase it's not it's our Nets
in America that's how we're doing it I
had these green our net sunglasses bro
you think I don't have the feeling I
have right now I can nostalgically [ __ ]
and feel the feeling of having the our
net sunglasses on thug I felt like I
felt I thought you know what I felt like
that's how I felt to be like Chris are
you gonna [ __ ] go - yeah are you
gonna go get a bagel with us and I'd be
like sorry guys I have English class
and I put on my Arnett sunglasses dude
they were green and they were a little
shiny and then my uncle give me a little
shot for wearing them and I was like I
made that one where I'm all that long
you know that much anymore
oh post Malone has a deal with our net
Jesus they're still around but they
don't look like they used to I mean they
used to look [ __ ] sick in 1998 ha ha
ha
you candled that you can wear our net
sunglasses those kinds without putting
gel in your hair for real dude Asians
had [ __ ] 5 or 6 our net sunglasses
you weren't technically Asian if you
didn't have all [ __ ] a bunch of our
net sunglasses and then also drove a
[ __ ] acura integra for real and also
Asians either have a picture of
themselves on the dash hanging from the
[ __ ] what do you call it the rearview
mirror not the rearview mirror or they
have a picture of them and their car in
their wallet that's how it was in the
90s either or if you didn't you weren't
you were you were like secretly Indian
and you know I know that that's over
there but like you were not at you were
not Korean like there's no way Korean
neither have a picture of them on their
[ __ ] rear-view mirror in their car or
a picture of them and their car in their
wallet and that's that and that's that
and I don't make these rules dude you
think I'm wrong you think I'm wrong you
wonder if it can be mad with me take it
up with Jesus Christ dude so take it up
with Jesus Christ and take it up with
Christ dude hey that's what I'm gonna
definitely my new argument stop her I
take it up with Christ that's what I'm
gonna say to Wahlberg that's what I'm
gonna say to Wahlberg when we get them
you know you don't [ __ ] talk to me
like that hey dude really take it up
with Christ that will probably get him
cuz you know he's religious I don't even
know if he was Elisabet you know he's
religious it's from Boston everybody in
Boston they're the most religious people
in the world dude it's so [ __ ] Irish
dude Wow
anyway dude guilt I don't know what the
[ __ ] I was talking about but it kind of
just went on the stream of consciousness
and [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah our Nets yeah
our Nets yeah they were the [ __ ] I had
the feeling of it sometimes you can feel
[ __ ] that used to happen I had used to I
don't wear Cologne you know that because
there's no caprara Cologne there's just
perfume and if you put on and if you're
a man and you put on Cologne
congratulations you're a female that put
on perfume and that's all good we're not
judging but turn around let's go to date
dude that's all good
hey bro you wore cologne all good what
are you doing later it's all good I
don't know and I don't judge you but
would you like to go to a movie sometime
hey hey guy all good
spray what you want on your [ __ ] neck
my only question is would you like to go
to a matinee sometime because there's no
because it's for fume and I'll be inside
you later maybe in a few dates so so
yeah so I used to when I was a kid you
know I would still try and spray Cologne
I'll try you know ice figure myself out
I had the are net sunglasses and I had
two colognes that were the [ __ ] I tried
three cold water Cologne didn't really
like it then I tried [ __ ] Fahrenheit
that [ __ ] every time I smell it now even
still that sends me back dude I love
Fahrenheit that smell is this [ __ ] but
only because isn't it nest algae and
then there was an old one that I don't
think is around anymore it might be but
it was called Paco and I got that cuz my
friend Brendan good he got it and he was
like it's the [ __ ] and he was kind of
good with chicks so I was like I'll get
Paco girls will be slipping and falling
all over the place I'll need to get up
I'll get Paco I'm taller than Brendan my
than Brandon my off my shoulders
they [ __ ] you know they travel out
the distance and Brandon's were way
closer to his
therefore I'll have to I'll have to get
Paco at Target because I'm also gonna
have to pick up some towels
for the girls innocent so I got Paco and
he was still better with chicks but um I
got Paco and then I got and then I got a
and I got Fahrenheit and those were the
shit's and cold water cool water cool
water is what it was not cold water
that's what that's the that's a street
in the valley cool water cool water cuz
Snoopy is just used to rap about that
[Music]
anyway and then and then I was like what
the [ __ ] am i doing dude
you know you got to figure out who you
are you really do and then you got to
make some mistakes and that's okay
that's how you figure out who you are
and you got to keep making mistakes too
you can't you know I think changing your
mind is a good thing for sure for sure
and I made a mistake with Paco and I'm
in a mistake with you know Fahrenheit
still smells good but I'm in a mistake
because you can't put Cologne and if
you're just you know you can but it's
perfume and you're a woman and it's all
good and it's all good
so yeah so our net sunglasses I'd love
to see some now just some new Ornette
sunglasses I've never haven't seen him
in a long time but it doesn't really
matter that much by the way you can
probably get him I wonder if they had
much sunglass hut I thought it was
sunglasses hot I didn't see that what
does it say sunglasses I thought it was
sunglasses hot but it's sunglass hut and
it should be it should be it should be
sunglasses hot I figured that out I
figured that out so yeah you know and
that's it my girl was laughing at me cuz
she was like it's sunglass it's sunglass
hut and I was like well it shouldn't be
and it shouldn't be it should be
sunglasses hot because it's not a
[ __ ] Hut made out of sunglasses that
would be sunglass hut that would be
sunglass hut mud hut right mud mud hut
what other kind of Hut is there I don't
know there's only a mud hut straw hut
sunglass hut
I'm gonna go and we'll [ __ ] sunglass
hut and be like hey what's the deal you
guys lie dude with these walls
it's Sunglasses Hut because there are
sunglasses in the hut it's also not a
hut they should call it sunglasses mall
room sunglasses store
it's a [ __ ] sunglasses store dude
sunglass hut dude don't try and be cute
with me you think when I go to Denny's I
get I [ __ ] I look at the waiter in
eyes and I say I'll take the moons over
my hammy eat my [ __ ] no way would I
ever say that dude eat my whole [ __ ]
dude I say I want this one
if that's what I want and hopefully the
waiters not blind because I'm not
getting it if she is oh well what is
that sir I'm blind
Oh give me a [ __ ] turkey sandwich for
[ __ ] sake dude I'm gonna get the toucan
no dude Denny's now look I'm a big fan
at Denny's you know that cuz I hand
outside I hand out grasslands all day
long right I hand out grants EPS to Mark
Wahlberg in my head I've got him stored
in case I'm on transformers 9 but dude
you know like Denny's are you gonna make
me say moons over my hammy that's the
thing about [ __ ] Denny's is you know
there's some either guy in a Borderlands
like live we're gonna think of something
cute marketing or they're like let's
[ __ ] with everyone and make them have to
say moons over my hammy who even knows
what moons over my moon over Miami what
is it it was that like a song or
something moon over Miami that sounds
like some [ __ ] [ __ ] Frank Sinatra
would sing and also everyone else would
sing too like there would be the Dean
Martin version the Frank Sinatra version
the [ __ ] Sammy Davis jr. version and
then the other guys that look like just
[ __ ] date was a date rape and looking
one on the Rat Pack
over Miami in your eyes
let's talking about eyes in those old
song what is it
Moo right oh it's a Sun Ray Charles see
there you go
moon over Miami the such a [ __ ]
chauvinistic song too no doubt secretly
moon over Miami women don't count brown
not that attached hey there you shut up
[ __ ] that's moon over Miami in the
moonlight I can see that you're less the
medes um you know so yeah I already did
every dessert every disease ship station
when you're selling online getting your
orders out can be a real pain now listen
I use ship station for all of the my
merch
you know people tweet me oh I ordered
the the shirt and I got it a day later I
got a two days later this is because of
ship station getting your oars out can
be a real pain a lot of the time it can
be time-consuming expensive so many
carriers to choose from how do you know
you're making the best choice well I'm
telling you to make this choice ship
station calm it's the fastest easiest
and most affordable way to manage and
ship your orders I use it babies ship
station helps you get your orders out
quickly save money on shipping costs and
keep your order keep your consumers
happy no matter what you're selling
Amazon Etsy your own website ship
station brings all your orders into one
simple interface you need this if you're
selling something they make them really
easy to manage from any device even your
cell phone they offer big discounts on
shipping costs which is great now any
business can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved for
a large fortune 500 companies what are
you a fortune 500 company because you're
accessing those large posters those
postage discount
that are usually reserved for them
you'll always know you're getting the
best deal it's the number one choice of
online sellers shipstation and right now
my listeners can try shipstation free
for 60 days when you use promo code
Congrats there's absolutely no risk you
can start your free trial without even
entering your credit card info just
visit shipstation com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in congrats
that's shipstation comm then enter promo
code congrats shipstation comm make ship
happen um look I work out a lot
obviously because my shoulders can tell
you the forecast of next week but it's
time to demand more from your workout
gear the way you demand more from
yourself I demand a lot for myself I
demand a lot from my workout care no
bull is on a mission to create products
built for people who train hard day
after day and my babies I'll tell you
right now that's me we're in Terre is
welcome no bull has you covered simple
and functional design grounded in
performance no gimmicks no excuses which
is what I like about it just thoughtful
and durable products built for people
who train hard a lot of my shoes that
aren't Noble or you know like the
outfits that I wear they go they go they
go quick they've run I burn through them
but they're durable Noble and they're
built for people who train hard and
babies that's me multi environment
design built for whatever wherever your
workout takes you trainers design for
cross-training weightlifting intervals
cardio and whatever else your training
condition
made with extremely durable breathable
and abrasion resistant material runners
breathable stretch knit upper that moves
with you
apparel the most comfortable apparel day
for the most uncomfortable training
training fundamentals you knew go to
workout care it's great for simple
durable and functional training gear
visit noble project comm / Congrats
training gear for people who work hard
and don't believe in excuses
visit noble project.com / Congrats
get and get your gear today that's n OB
u ll p ro j ECT calm / congrats
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app the app that likes when you pet
it almost hit when I threw the thing
almost hit one fire in the face didn't
mean to I'm being respectful so that's
what's up dude you know that's the
commercial break and that great
yeah so it's [ __ ] sunglass hut
[ __ ] it's Sunglasses Hut
this is what it should be right I'm
checking my text cuz I'm respectful Anja
I do what I do in my life in the podcast
and welcome for that I'm not gonna be
one of these [ __ ] I was looking at uh
was it looking at something somebody was
doing something some personality was
doing something and it was so happy
go-lucky
and I must had to [ __ ] my pants but it's
all good I didn't you guys seen that
first of all have you seen that the the
venmo or the XXX tent asean thing I
don't remember the names of either
parties involved that started it
actually don't know if i knew some
comedian named Dina made this joke or
Dinah made this joke on Comedy Central
about the slain rapper head and it was a
joke you know and then I think James
Davis comedian was a comedian that
originally said this is offensive or
something and I don't really know enough
about it but I just saw that the fallout
of it and everyone was like out well
there were a lot of xxx nación fans that
were sending death threats to the
the comedian that did it and Comedy
Central retracted it and I guess
apologized for it and the whole thing
about the whole thing I just have to say
know about the whole thing
because here are the things if comedy is
comedy if there is comedy then you just
you're allowed to just make whatever
joke there is and you're just gonna
offend some people and that's not a bad
thing
that's a good thing because that's what
makes comedy comedy all jokes are
offensive to somebody otherwise it's not
even a [ __ ] joke dude if I make a if
I make a joke about somebody's
refrigerator I say I add this
refrigerator it [ __ ] sucks cuz of
this whatever the Volcom do that's a
hilarious joke by the way but if it was
even funnier than that somebody's but I
that's [ __ ] that's my refrigerate go
[ __ ] yourself it's cuz it's gonna be
offensive to somebody or the person's
not gonna give a [ __ ] whatever but it's
like you can't pick and choose
especially as a comedian you can't call
out another comedian for making fun of
first of all it was a joke regardless of
whether or not you think it was good it
was a joke it was a joke form
I think the joke was something like rat
rapper exercises tend to assume God got
killed for carrying $50,000 on his
person I'm butchering the joke but
that's the best venmo commercial ever
right don't carry any cash just use
venmo whatever the [ __ ] joke was i
don't know what it was funnier than that
but yeah that's a joke
period and to say all as a comedian you
can't you can't say that [ __ ] that then
you're not a you're not really a
comedian because you know and i see i
saw other people on twitter is like yeah
it's the fact that it wasn't funny
that's the offensive part you don't get
to pick you can personally say that's
not funny for me
but if Comedy Central is going to put
something out there they already did
that you can't take it apparently they
took it off the internet and they're
like we're sorry they're not they're not
taking it off the
internet because they're because of
their taking off the internet because
the mob is why they take off the
internet and that's not okay because
people are gonna be offended I mean for
[ __ ] sake the joke really wasn't even
that offensive if you said this [ __ ]
about Michael Jackson nobody would give
a [ __ ] if you said the [ __ ]
and-and-and-and is he's got all these
alleged [ __ ] things about how he beat
up his pregnant girlfriend or whatever
you know and you know I know he's never
proven in a court of law but neither was
a Jackson [ __ ] but it's just like wow
you know it's because of his rabid fan
base I think dude let me just tell you
if people make jokes about me just if I
ever get to the level where you know
people are just like slamming me or
whatever it's all good babies you don't
need to tell people to go kill
themselves it's all good man
jokes its intent it's this and that I
get it but like dude we're allowed to
make all the jokes and we're allowed to
go too far because that's how we figure
out what [ __ ] jokes are funny and
that's how you keep pushing that's why
stuff listen man listen that's why stuff
that was made in 1930 isn't funny
anymore because we've advanced beyond
that if you don't keep pushing the
envelope we'll be stuck with Laurel and
[ __ ] Hardy dude they'll be trying to
push a [ __ ] piano up the stairs and
we'll be like the whole reason why
shit's funny now is because you have the
people that will push that [ __ ]
envelope and I'm not saying Laurel and
Hardy isn't funny but we're past that
dude we're past that because of people
who make jokes like the [ __ ] one on
Comedy Central
whether you think it's funny or not you
have to figure it out you got to push it
otherwise you're gonna be the [ __ ]
cuck [ __ ] that's still laughing at
[ __ ] you know whatever it is in black
and white at the [ __ ] thing dude
stuff isn't funny
[ __ ] 60 years later because of that
so if you're
if you're a comedian dude go to war for
the comedian I don't care if you like
the guys [ __ ] music look I thought
the guys music uh I'm not a fan of the
guy but the guy's music was incredible I
liked his music you know he's a talented
guy you can't say he's not talented just
because of what his person was like but
dude the whole [ __ ] thing is in st.
IIIi just you know there's countless
things in my set that could you know
catch fire and and be like ah this is
shitty that they said this and that he
said that but it's just the [ __ ]
story of the goddamn day so shout out
who was the the comedian that said the
joke dinah what Dena Hashim don't worry
you know I know you're getting [ __ ]
slaughtered by a xxx 10,000 fans but
it's gonna be [ __ ] fine you know it's
so [ __ ] shitty to tell people to go
kill themselves online it's so [ __ ]
shitty dude grow the [ __ ] up grow up and
if you're 13 for real grow up because
like dude you're gonna look back at
yourself and you're gonna be like oh I
shouldn't have done that I'm a [ __ ]
Laurel and Hardy watcher in 2019 dude go
watch some [ __ ] Yuk Yuk's push a
piano up a flight of stairs you stupid
[ __ ] that's a good that would be a good
insult in my head if I was arguing with
a [ __ ] you know kick ass but now I
said it so I can't use it anymore it's
just like dude get it together man
it's so it's so [ __ ] annoying dude I
tried to follow Dana on Twitter so you
know I had to ask she [ __ ] cuz you now
she's private because she doesn't want
[ __ ] people coming up to her saying
they're gonna keep people online saying
go kill yourself dude also how about the
fact that hey don't don't make jokes
about someone who was killed or will
kill you
yeah you [ __ ] idiot do you realize
what you're doing you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
you can it's it's not America if you
can't say whatever you want to say you
know I said it's in my act you can get
mad at somebody for saying something but
you can't tell him not to say it uh so
yeah by the way it was a venmo joke it
wasn't a [ __ ] XXX tenth asean joke it
was a venmo joke so you're getting
offended at a venmo joke you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you're getting offended at a venmo joke
all good all good go watch some [ __ ]
guys who look different than each other
push up a piano on a on a flight of
stairs you you know [ __ ] that's just so
lame get a hobby go to Sunglasses Hut
get some our nets put them on get some
gel and go drive a [ __ ] acura integra
around in 1998 now that's a [ __ ]
goddamn slam it's a lot of words but it
is a slam and you have walked into
Denny's
and I'm so sorry but all we have right
now are the grade-a all-american Slams
that's what we have here you go
eat it while I go like this did what if
you were out of [ __ ] restaurant and
you and the waiter was watching you eat
and he was home bro bro I want to get a
job as a waiter just so I could [ __ ]
serve someone fee and then sit over
while I was at like doing other work as
a waiter whatever the [ __ ] else they do
but behind the thing get other food
ready and then I just every now and then
look over me and I'm going like this
bro you'd be like what the [ __ ] is this
real is this a [ __ ] David Lynch movie
that's the most disrespectful thing you
can do in the world to somebody is to
look at them and go right in their
[ __ ] face I'm gonna start doing that
in Albuquerque that could be my thing in
Albuquerque hey um you know like like in
oh oh I was in a [ __ ] Starbucks
recently and I was like yeah can I get a
oh this was I had a [ __ ] slam to me
the lady [ __ ] it took me to Denny's dude
I was in Starbucks and she took me to
Denny's hello chain central and she goes
uh the worker there first of all she
wasn't even ringing me up there was
someone ringing me up and she was like
hi how can I help you and I was like
yeah can I get an iced americano because
you know how we do my babies and she was
like cause I can have an iced americano
and she was like sure what sighs and I
said uh the regular kind I don't know I
know I don't know and then my I think
was my opener he was like it wasn't him
it was somebody else but he was like
dude it's I still don't know what it is
whatever sighs it was the middle for
Starbucks you know they got like venti
Grande he go [ __ ] yourself whatever and
then I and I was like yeah I'm not I
don't know what it is just regular I'm
not gonna say this [ __ ] you know it's
medium and I said I'm not saying that
it's it's it i said it's silly or
something i i sounds like that's so
stupid I'm gonna say some and then and
then the lady that worked there that was
stocking the [ __ ] she looks at me and
she says stupid why is it stupid and I
was like what are you doing
stocke the ethos water or whatever it's
called you know I mean you're us what
the [ __ ] are called there used to be a
website there you get hookers on called
eros I used to look at it with my
friends like we think that's the one
that shows up nope that's why the
[ __ ] faces are turned around that's
why their other [ __ ] Russian eyes are
blurred out so she was like she was like
why is it stupid and I was like I
actually have nothing to say to that
and she Lou goes like this I was like oh
my god dude she took me directly to
Denny's [ __ ] murdered me and I was
like oh yeah I don't know just whatever
it is it's all the same so I did that I
don't know what I was talking about
before that but it [ __ ] doesn't
matter cuz this podcast is you know but
this podcast um there's so many guitars
in this room right now by the way so you
know I'm loving it
you know yeah it was a venmo go joke he
got mad at of my joke was what I said
and then sunglasses happen sunglass hut
and there's Starbucks and then it's all
good
have you seen ah the ice cream licking
challenge that people are talking about
they should be calling it the [ __ ]
how long you can go to jail for a
challenge because people just go out you
should look this up you just did go out
and they have you've heard about this
you have oh okay I thought I was onto
some new [ __ ] and they they [ __ ] go
in to like a Rite Aid and they grab they
go to the ice cream they grab it open it
up lick it and then put it back dude if
I saw someone do that I'd sweep them I'd
sweep them
I'd sweep him I do a [ __ ] one of
those spin sweeps and they'd go on there
they fall down on their ass dude if I
see someone do that mud sweep them if
you see someone do that sweep then go
for the leg what's the [ __ ] uh
sweep the leg in Karate Kid that's me do
it I'm gonna bring a blonde haired dude
in right aids look for people like that
when we see it I'm gonna hear him say
sweep the leg and I'm gonna go for the
leg do it I'm gonna do a spin sweep I
hope it hurts dude because that's you
you're gonna go to jail for that that's
malpractice
I mean I know you're not a doctor but
that's my practice you might be a doctor
maybe do an ice cream the challenge and
yeah ended and you are doctor now that's
my practice and I will see you I'll buy
the ice cream eat it to sue you they
understand me unless you have a gross
mouth some people have grossest [ __ ]
mouths huh you ever talk to somebody and
they're talking with their mouth and
you're just like whoa what are you doing
like what is going on in there you know
like they got weird teeth or like that
weird [ __ ] yellow like or like
sometimes it's like grey in their mouth
and you're just like you feel like
you're looking at like they're like
[ __ ] like you dare you ever feel that
the same way you're like why did you why
did you show me that you know that's all
I feel when sometimes people talk to me
and then I'm looking in their mouth
talking and I'm just like why are you
showing me this if someone like that did
eyes that did the ice cream challenge
dude hey ass meet the floor cuz you're
getting sweep yeah
are you some dust cuz you're getting
swept I'm a janitor boom sweep you're on
your anything oh yeah dude that's it's
just yeah the ice cream challenge that's
so [ __ ] up or or or I would do this
from across the way if I saw you do that
have a go like I will be I would I will
put my fist up and I would be running
toward you and I'd be like here comes a
punch in the face and then boom hit you
and you wouldn't anywhere I would have a
cover connected
either the sweep or here comes up once
in the face similar to the ice-cream Oh
get oh here's another one that he's
sending me get oh oh yeah the gallon
smashing this is less bad but it's real
bad the the gallon Smith oh good good
good
congratulations Wow I just saw a guy do
it the bro that's the dumbest thing I've
ever seen in my life it's also very very
white to do that this is so white gallon
smashing compilation the first guy takes
the gallon smashing smashes the two
gallons of milk slips and [ __ ]
smashes his jaw we don't even need to
sweep this guy oh he's so Irish ha kick
it broke me draw it no you know what I
bet he's from like Austin Texas and
became Irish that's how hard he hit his
head he's that yeah y'all wanna do the
[ __ ] gone set it smashing cowboy you
want to do down smashing what's that boy
that's when you take them to market you
take gallon milk and just smash it on
the ground the guy says long gallon
we're gonna do - I guess says well
alright sounds dangerous but let's do it
and they go and they do it and they
[ __ ] got the two gallons and get
mental record this and does it swung
boom hits so hard he's gone Oh puppy
Joel immediate [ __ ] cockney
watch me go
the [ __ ] hard to watch that's
really really really hard to watch and
I've seen Seaquest cows ting dude you
know it's like with the gallon the
gallon
smashing competition and then they get
in the [ __ ] one time my brother and I
you know those we were we were dumb but
we were really young you know those uh
what do you call him coupons things that
you would they will be in the aisle and
you could just take one and then another
one will pop out
my brother and I would collect him we
would run around the whole stores and
and [ __ ] open it and it would go Boop
and then no one we were on the whole
story and then this guy to shoot that
was we were in New Jersey but he was so
New Jersey was like all right guys all
right fellas you gotta give him you got
to stop doing that and I was like it
when I felt so bad I went back to my
mom's like mom we got in trouble these
kids are [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what
these kids are they're all rich it's
like they got too much [ __ ] their
family has too much money
it's so not me it here's the number-one
thing it's so not worth it you know like
what's the thing oh they gotta clean it
up okay someone saw you for uh it's so
you're basically the guy at the
Halloween party that dressed up in the
outfit that's like like a you're like
you're the person who put on a slip and
wrote Freud on it and you're like and
they're like I'm a Freudian slip and
this is and then I go AHA yeah that's
you you're the [ __ ] fun guy at the
Halloween party you [ __ ]
but also you're making putting people
out look what I am I'm your your dresses
a chicken and you got a cord connected
to you to a blue circle and you're like
look I'm chicken cordon bleu oh cool man
haha you made a play on words Halloween
costume dude you're the first to go
look at these gallon smashing oh and
then he's hamming it up falling down
like he's like his Buster Keaton
it's so not funny good its what not
funny people do too because they don't
have personalities so they just cuz
they're slipping it's not even worth
recording do it right so stupid dude all
good all good if I saw someone do that I
take the gallon and throw another gallon
on them or just dump it out on him one
time oh dude
one time you know how you know how oh
dude this is how I was as a kid one time
somebody poured something on my head
as like a joke and I was a kid I was a
kindergarten kid or whatever it was or
maybe I was in first or second grade bro
this is the kind of kid I was okay so
you know unlike shows when somebody
pours a glass on somebody's head they
pour a little bit on it and it's real
quick and the person just goes like this
and they just sit there when in real
life of course you would go like yo what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] and grab their hand and
they're coupled go flying and [ __ ] and
be all awkward but in movies and TV
shows especially in the 80s which was
when I was a kid somebody would pour
some on your head and the person would
just go like this and if they had long
hair they go right all right so somebody
did that to me I don't number who it was
I think it was Sumatra she was like this
little girl who in in my in my
first-grade class - that one time we
were doing answers in the class room and
she was like what's another one class
and I was like I think this is an answer
and so much or where's her hand and said
my answer and I go that was my [ __ ]
answer she said well you didn't say it
you should have said it then I stole it
from you and I was like wow that's a
life lesson from Sumatra who knew right
what she's doing now she's 40 that's
crazy
so anyway somebody did I think it was
some mantra she poured something on my
head behind me and it was like a big it
wasn't just a couple's like a lot and I
did the thing that they do in movies and
go and I waited and she [ __ ] this
[ __ ] kept pouring on the [ __ ] and I
waited an extra second I was like what
do you doing dude and she was like well
why aren't you moving and I was like to
be freaking like the movies could you
suppose them for a little bit and then I
let me do my thing but life isn't like
the movies you know and that's what I
realized that when I was [ __ ] 8 and
so much up or some like a whole powering
on me um anyway how many minutes has it
been 54 alright well you know this has
been really fun it's so Albuquerque and
we had a good time it's nice and cool in
the studio to Rio Grande studios shout
out to them for letting us do it all
right here and I guess that's that
do we are there there's no yeah because
we don't have the screen so what else
can we talk about maybe one more thing I
guess what's a park fifty five minutes
is good quirky so download download the
cash up for free download the cash up
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market and also download the crystal Lea
app you can watch the episode live
earlier than anyone else or earlier than
that comes out ever for anyone support
the show oh there's a lot of merch
there's my future too bright t-shirt
he's got custom sunglasses on it store
crystal calm or just go to Chris they're
calm and we run we can get gift cards at
the store too at my store too as well by
clicking the gift card link at the top
and subscribe to the youtube channel
please that really helps we're trying to
get those followers it helps us do the
show and it helps us make more money to
do the show and [ __ ] like that and
making more money is what we're all you
know is what we're all about
if you ain't need for them for the
[ __ ] money there was your
purpose may that's that was in a song by
to park that and that one that outlaw
said it and they were talking about
exhibit anyway subscribe rate and review
the show and all that video episodes go
up a day after the audio
and that's cool I'm shooting this movie
army of army of the Dead and it's so
awesome the crew and the cast is amazing
can't say too much about it because I'm
you know I'm gonna let them do their
thing I don't know what they want us to
it and not say say or not say so it was
a very cool picture of us zombie killers
on my Instagram go check it out and it's
hot as [ __ ] in Albuquerque but it's fun
I'm having a good time so report on that
videos how about that
thanks a lot you guys
[Music]